come on mermaid
in the heart of the welsh valleys farmer
mossy hassanin tends to his land and
animals he's one of a small group of
people from ethnic minorities in the uk
who are working in farming
an industry that's nearly 100
white
it's not really something that you know
people from ethnic backgrounds really
look at because
it's like it's a very very closed
group you know um you know even just
going to the auction house for example
you don't know what's going on you know
that was sitting there we went there one
time and i was like what is going on
here like this is another language i
never saw myself as a farmer i saw
myself as someone who bought land it
dropped a few years later when i was
like i've got cows i've got goats i've
got geese i've got ducks or chickens i'm
farming this is farming you know so
that's when i kind of call myself the
british muslim farmer at that point
figures show that last year 97.2
of the british agriculture forestry and
fishing sector was made up of white
workers excluding seasonal staff some of
the reasons are obvious rural parts of
the country are less diverse farms tend
to be handed down through the
generations but now one of the country's
leading farming institutions wants to
tackle the issue
the royal agricultural university in
gloucestershire is launching two new
undergraduate scholarships exclusively
for those from ethnic minority groups we
definitely think that there needs to be
space for everyone to to play a part in
in agriculture in the land-based sector
if we can educate more people if we can
train more people from a broader range
of backgrounds
then there'll be more people available
in the future who have got the skills
and the qualifications and the interest
to actually go on and make a difference
in that sector and in those jobs
[Applause]
at the stepney city farm in london young
people from all backgrounds get hands-on
experience
but many feel farming isn't an easy
industry to enter i think it's partly to
do with not knowing that farming is an
acceptable profession to go into and not
knowing how to go into it not knowing
that it
is a job because for a lot of people
it's just what everyone does in their
home country
food experts say diversity in our
population should be reflected in food
production we do want to break that mold
over being uh you know
ultimately an old white man and a
tractor what we do need to see is a
better diversity within the foods that
we're producing and those skills are
being lost if they're not being
invested into our entire food and
farming
sector while there aren't calls for
diversity quotas in farming many believe
more work is needed to ensure the
industry is open to all
that white is sky news in south wales